[Music]
in Darwinism at its finest news natural
selection yeah yeah submitted by party
at Joe's house oh we haven't had that
yet you know wait till the summer it's
been raining too much too much
I saw your housewarming or your house
tour video that [ __ ] was funny
thank you very much hey where can i
watch them on my channel George it's of
Cour no I wish I had a house I wish I
wasn't [ __ ] the nice areas hey [ __ ]
it Armenian Glendale oh you got a lot of
restaurants next to you it's it's almost
like you get the best of both worlds
because you get downtown LA without the
filth yeah but then I also get the angry
Armenian men oh yeah what an aggressive
culture Armenian people fella I don't
like you know you think that's a
stereotype but just culturally speaking
if they're just very aggressive like
they like MMA and coach in karate
that makes [ __ ] sense because I was
talking to one of like the Armenian
dudes over there he goes
you know just where our culture is just
very aggressive like even he said that
even when he was a kid that's how his
dad spoke to him and that's how they
talk to all the relatives so don't take
it personally yeah like what's an
example of something aggressive that
they say just like for example like if
they ask you to do something fear in the
way they're like what are you doing it
won't be like excuse me oh it's just
like oh good they're not saying it to
fight all the time I just hope that's
how they communicate by NASA it's
interesting to me because I chase the
guy from System of a Down is Armenian so
when you say that I'm imagining him like
yodeling when he says office Leigh is
very anecdotal because it's from my
personal like 10,000 experiences but I
have the same as yours yeah I mean also
it's coming from an Armenian friend that
says our culture's just tends to be very
aggressive so I'm assuming that okay
when the do talks to me like that it's
just how they are I'm just gonna let it
go it's probably just aggressive to us
yeah but to them that's just everyday
because they make Korean people look
like Japanese people
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah that's absurd dude
okay a woman was attacked by a Jaguar
while trying to take a selfie people
thinking what was she trying to take a
she's like oh there's a Jaguar and she's
trying to take a [ __ ] selfie with the
Jaguar in the back I know she crossed
the barrier oh you [ __ ] oh it's not
in the US it's probably that Chinese Zoo
especially in the US we're in a zoo
could this sounded Chinese is [ __ ] no I
wasn't in a zoo in Phoenix oh I was
thinking because China has these zoos
where you could drive through them one
with the Tigers but this one had
barriers and she crossed it and then
that's when a Jaguar like clawed at her
arm oh my god when we're trying to
create another Koko huh Harambee you're
trying to have a horrible situation yeah
did it kill her on me so I'm gonna show
you guys a video clip of should I let
that boy just [ __ ] chill with
Harambee one of the witnesses had I'm
bigger I like it like that dude so it's
graphic good epic - close your eyes
I don't know watch you know I want to
see it this is nature because the people
[ __ ] with animals [ __ ] them I'll watch
it during the wall they found or like
they got hurt like they're rescued her
if you only use the animals to eat
that's okay what did they do to the
Jaguar I hope nothing why does that look
like your mom on the floor dude because
like why would we euthanize an innocent
animal I had nothing to do with this it
was her fault and then she ended up
going back to the zoo after and
apologizing and saying I'm at fault Oh
but you're learning okay here we go she
was just too excited oh wait - anything
yet are you see all the red the skin is
open you could get fat your clothes are
like blood that's a deep blade just try
it yourself II got it just take a selfie
right now then did they kill the Jaguar
no miss induce money
all right billboard and the Sun yeah I
should feel sorry but this is really
satisfying it's kind of funny something
really profound but it was so big going
back and forth between you stupid [ __ ]
I'm happy this happened to you but then
I'm trying to like not sound that way
fight yourself do because that [ __ ] was
funny
think of all the [ __ ] nuts and bolts
ago
[Music]
[Laughter]
like the Disney cartoons that you also
like you short-circuited killing me like
what she's saying right now it he has a
[ __ ] dial that is spinning wait was
it like a bite or was it a scratch
there's a scratch but you could see like
scratch she jumped over the barrier or
like she kind of cross like she was
crossing you this sounds like a very
unsafe zoo by the way if there's just a
barrier keeping you from the foot and
the [ __ ] what was what's the cage
openings like this big in between were
the [ __ ] arm goes up like the whole
Jago to stick his head out like this
yeah I wouldn't turn my back on a
predator just doesn't make sense
oh yeah you're right this does sound
like it happened for a country we know
America I actually saw one of her one of
our editors at Smosh and I'm pretty sure
he posted about this on Instagram so
like cut whatever we we were like
shooting one day we were like yo where's
Spencer and they were walking to go to
the emergency room because he decided to
like go off on his own in San Diego and
he took a picture with a seal and the
seal bitumen and like he like he went to
take a picture with the sealer would
have thought that a seal would bite she
was aggressive assault can be aggressive
and she's PSA all [ __ ] wild animals
are wild all right even a cute little
bunny or turtles I take a selfie with
they bite the foot body you are you
kidding me yeah babe I don't see turtles
oh why would I doing what a snapping
turtle you did see a turtle
the only turtles that I've taken selfies
with or sea turtles she's gonna be our
next article first attacked by a sea
turtle no you know what that's why I was
so scared when we went to go visit that
wolf singer me too we're gonna take it
so like we're saying you're the wolf and
I was just like it me too we're not fool
third they're half I know but they're so
animal freakin huge
I got scared of a good thing I could
read their body language cuz I knew oh
you're half alligator I'm still gonna be
scared in fact I might be more fearful
because what the [ __ ] play have anything
half wolf I was like alright I'm gonna
kick it over here I love animals but
y'all but the energy feels friendly not
mop from you did it oh you know the
Crocodile Hunter I just saw this tribute
video
oh man made me miss him so much it was
so [ __ ] good fun kid kids are cute as
[ __ ] whether older now but they're just
like their dad's like super outgoing
yeah the donger that feels like God
major ADHD I didn't realize that I
didn't recognize that when I was
watching him back then but that fool is
always a thousand percent energy even
when there's this one where he's like
he's like [ __ ] far away right but
he's still projecting to the camera with
a thousand percent energy so when he's
like at this cavern and [ __ ] and if he's
like he's like [ __ ] a thousand
percent like and you can feel that [ __ ]
even though he's far away he was the
person that mastered how to yell while
whispering you see that
you gotta keep real quiet like bro
you're laughing at [ __ ] dude
whispering yeah make sure you're not
like I feel like the entertainment
industry realize they stumble on a
goldmine because they were like dude
this guy's great on camera
he'll also put his arm in a [ __ ] the
alligator's mouth
like who are you gonna find that's gonna
do that and is actually good on camera
to show you what you're not supposed to
do he's all like I'll take all
everybody's money and I don't care where
the money comes from
I'll take it all and you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna spend it all on land
I'm gonna keep it natural that's all I'm
gonna do I don't care what the money
comes from and he just kept saying that
over and over he knows I thought the
[ __ ] so you take money from drug dealers
like I don't know what he's saying where
is he getting it I think you think he
would have had like a free zoo he's like
open millions and millions and millions
of dollars and I'll just use it for
conservatives conservatory land oh my
god I was like that's all you wanted to
do that was his like dogs doesn't hold
but see that's the thing that we don't
know what we see when were kids but when
we're an adult we could see it with an
adult lens yeah so I'm pretty sure our
parents or that generation saw it as a
crazy man but as kids we don't see that
Yeah right
we just see someone that's like loves
animal because I don't really
entertaining cuz even with all like the
whole Michael Jackson controversy stuff
I don't I know of it
but I don't know of it you know so I
know it was happening but all I know is
me all that remembers me trying to be
Michael Jackson doing all the dad stuff
in the moonwalk but I don't remember all
the other [ __ ] with it
I love well I remember it wait did it
come around junior high I had a friend
that went to Neverland Ranch because he
came out okay yeah I mean like did they
have like tickets it was everything free
everything's free
no he's not like so he said that he
didn't it to meet Michael but then they
would have these events all the time
right now I'm just picturing like did he
have Scouts or like no no they would use
his property all the time for different
events like and then he was like he was
like a pro golfer kind of thing like you
can't see that pro but he was like up
there and then yeah alright yeah we were
junior high so he was like sixth grade
sixth grade or something and then so
yeah he said that they would have these
events they would go there they would
play like in the like the amusement park
they would get you know they would they
would just have events but then he
didn't get to meet him and so you
thought Michael Jackson saw him is that
he too old no there's nothing out there
cuz he didn't get to me no Michael
Michaels just up no but they would
always have charity events there so we
got cubes I don't like him these 200 200
he take them away
[Music]